today I want to speak to you about the
Dubai of South America
so what do you think about when you
think about Panama I'm not talking about
that Panama from Van Halen I'm talking
about Panama Canal see recently I just
came back from Panama Canal and I was
blown away by the country and now it
makes sense why people call Panama the
Dubai of South America literally there
are skyscrapers everywhere in Panama and
some of them are so creative things
you've probably never ever seen in North
American you wonder what is the story
about Panama there's a population of
roughly three and a half million people
their unemployment is three percent they
are a democracy the economy is booming
over there as long as you invest three
hundred thousand dollars in the economy
so if you put in a bank account or you
buy a property they consider you a
permanent resident so that's why a lot
of people are moving to Panama from
different parts of the world and last
but not least if you build the house in
Panama you pay 0% property tax for 10
years but why is that taking place well
when you think about Panama you think
about Panama Canal I think about Panama
Canal but I've never seen it before when
you see this project they built but it
started back in the 1500s the first time
they actually saw it and some people
thought about what could we do if we had
an opening here right the same people
that build the Suez Canal which is
connecting the Mediterranean Sea and the
Red Sea together are the same people
that came from France to develop the
Panama Canal but they failed in the late
een 1800s but in 1904 an engineer from
us called John Wallace comes down and
decides to build this project and
finalize it right to connect the
Atlantic Ocean to the Pacific Ocean and
this was an incredible project to
continues to do so and the reason why
this was very important because all the
ships that would come through whether
it's from China or Europe all the places
where the ships would come through in
order to go through South America from
point to point it took 45 days and they
thought about if we can find a way to
build this through that would be eight
hours point-to-point from Atlantic to
Pacific when I was there and I was
looking at the technology they use we're
talking roughly hundred years ago they
use 80 million tons of 80 million pounds
of
my people passed away regularly when the
rocks were fallen and they built three
locks so the way it would work is when
the ships would come because
common-sense like we would think if
we're not the engineers ourselves we
would say why don't they just blow the
whole thing up in the middle and let the
water kind of go through but it doesn't
work that way right there's a magnetic
challenge that they would have that the
water won't make it through and water
doesn't go uphill so there's mountains
to go through so how do they do this
well the way they did it is in the canal
the ship would come it goes into a lock
there's three sets of locks goes into a
lock the gates closed the gates are
roughly eight stories high the gates
closed like a door closes then would
fill it up with water to grow to raise
it eight stories high
then the gates open the locks open ship
goes into the next lock then it goes
again eight stories high then it goes
into the next lock then again another
eight story side then a lock opens and
then it opens up to go to the river and
it finds its way finally to the Pacific
Ocean this project obviously took ten
years it took a lot of effort a lot of
people's efforts but look what it did to
that country look what it did to a small
country like Panama to where the economy
is at right now
I was asking one of the workers over
that's it if I'm a cruise ship right
behind me when I was there there was a
cruise ship coming through us and we
were watching this thing taking place
line I said how much does a cruise ship
like that pay to go through the Panama
Canal
they said roughly somewhere run a
quarter million dollars think about that
roughly a quarter of a million dollars
to be able to go for eight hours instead
of 45 days to go through the canal so
the point I want to make is this it's
amazing what mankind is capable when a
group of people unify and they bind to
one cause together it doesn't matter how
big the obstacle is if an organization a
group of people come together and
they're united you hear the word United
States of America right not to divide it
when a group of people come together and
they're bottom to one cause together
practically anything is possible for
them to do because everybody has a
different strength different gift that
they bring together you set aside your
ego you bring all those gifts together
go out there and do whatever you want to
do as a group
it's my message of the week to you and
please make sure to subscribe
you